Đóng đơn công nghiệm bác Trung Quốc Nguồn Nguồn Cô thông báo đã thường nghiệm thành công chuyển mai đầu tiên,
của mấy bánh tài không người lại thiên mám của Nguồn Nguồn Cô,
toàn bố kê thống trên mấy bây hoàn đầm một đình, giữ liệu bài thu thập được điều đặt yêu cầu ki thuật dây ra.
Thì mám của Nguồn Nguồn Nguồn Cô, đối thích kế của vụ như nhiều vụ khăn nhau,
như vận chuyển hàng ngoá cứu hộ hình cấp và thả tiếp tế.
Mấy bây có khăn nân cấp và hả cạnh trường quán đường ngắn,
thì cướng video kiện địa hình phức tà, đã biệt tại các khu bự vùng cao, khó khả tân hạn chế.
Bới trên bây khoảng táng nghìn mấy và tâm hoàn đồng tuy ra một nghiệm tám chăm,
thì là mấy khi mám một nghiệm của tệ bánh chuyển tới một tấn năng,
ở trên một chuyển bây giờ qua sẽ trở săng bị thường nghiệm thành công thiên mám một nghiệm,
và nãy nỗ là của Trung Quốc trong việc mở giọng ngăn lực vận tài không người lại.
Hướng tới phục vụ cả một bây giờ sự như hậu cần ứng phó thiên tài và hỗ trợ ý tế.
Đồng thời có phần hoàn thiện địa sĩnh tài công nghiệp của W trong nước.